[Music]
[Music]
just the incarnate this mini series
we're doing is five issues but it is the
second act of the infinite frontier saga
that we're building it's a trilogy they
started with infinite frontier zero
following death metal so we have the
infinite frontier mini
then we have the justice league current
is sort of the second act but it also
kind of spreads out across the dcu and
you can see there are like little things
happening in the dcu that all kind of
connect and tie together by the time we
get to the third act in
2022 you'll see how it all really just
comes together
[Music]
with the team book it's hard to say just
like one character that i couldn't wait
to write
but the thing that i love writing
infinite frontier that i got to carry
over here
was the back and forth between
flashpoint batman and president superman
that was a super organic thing that
happened in the book that was not a plan
thing that wasn't something we had
originally like
mapped out in the outlines of like oh
we're gonna write them together and
we're gonna make this like multiverse
finest that was not the plan it came
organically while we were writing the
book and also captain carrot is a lot of
fun to write
the dynamic with the justice league
incarnate team for the most part they
get along at the beginning like the idea
is that like you know they've gone
through all this stuff together they've
been a team for a while they recognize
they're often different worlds but they
all have the same goals
however
in the first issue we get three new team
members you get avery ho who gets to be
the like i said before is the point of
view character and is sort of able to
give a different perspective on some of
these adventures but she's like the
young rookie then we get dr multiverse
who's a new character from earth eight
and she doesn't get along with some
members but definitely gets along with
others more and kind of creates a
conflict among the team and then we get
a third new member that we haven't
revealed yet and the third remember 100
creates a lot of tension
wayne from from flashpoint is such a
different character from bruce they have
such different voices like batman is
obviously angry but there's a kind of
obsession and there's a kind of
you know quest for justice with him
where i always felt like thomas was
searching for a kind of piece whereas
and i think thomas is like a blunt
instrument which is interesting because
he's a doctor right he's a person that
used to be a surgeon it needs to be
about precision
and then that kind of got taken away
from him like when his you know martha
and bruce died in the flashpoint world
completely changed him just made him
this much more angry person
[Music]
but so the plan is for every world that
they go to throughout the series each
world is drawn by a different artist so
in issue one they go to earth eight and
on that world we meet the retaliators
and that world is drawn by brandon
peterson and we felt like he was perfect
for that world and then you look at
issue two where they go to earth 13 and
earn 13 is a horror world and so we got
kyle holtz who is an amazing artist one
of my favorites he just excels at horror
and so we really leaned in to like make
this or make this creepy you know make
it very gothic and eroded for him as
that's been the thing we do consistently
for every artist
[Music]
so with darkseid he's you know he's the
dark audience the greatest evil dcu
or so he thought you know darkseid is
always obsessed with control like
everything about darkseid is always
about how he can control everything
everyone every situation every decision
like that's what the anti-life equation
is for him so the idea there's something
out there that he can't control
is frustrating and a little scary for
him normally he's the kind of character
that manipulates behind the scenes and
sends people out to do his bidding but
in this case he realizes that he's the
one that has to go and confront it
himself so that's the role that he plays
he plays a antagonist but he's also
realizing there's something really
bigger out there
[Music]
in justice league current number one the
team goes to earth
eight with the retaliators and darkseid
follows them and on that world there is
another cosmic god on earth eight that
dark side gets into like a straight up
fist fight with and it's this really
cool fight scene with a twist that i
think when people get to it they'll be
really excited
[Music]
you